President Trump spent part of his
weekend on Twitter condemning any
suggestion his presidential campaign
colluded with Russians he wrote
yesterday quote I never said Russia did
not meddle in the election the Russian
hoax was that the Trump campaign
colluded with Russia it never did the
president's comments stem from the
special counsels indictment on Friday it
accuses more than a dozen Russians of
carrying out a complicated meddling
scheme to influence the 2016 election
the document alleges Russians posed as
Americans and used social media to
influence the vote to former Trump
associates were implicated in the probe
last year Paula Reid is following the
latest developments
good morning Paula good morning the dust
is settled a little bit since Friday
what does the indict what are those
indictments mean what's them what's the
most important thing to take away from
them well this is very different than
the indictments and the charges that
we've seen against man afford against
gates against Papadopoulos because no
one here is likely to go to jail it's
highly unlikely that the Russian
government is going to extradite their
own citizens to face these charges so
legally speaking the significance of
this indictment is that it lays out in
specific details how the Russians
meddled in these elections and what
crimes were committed under US law
because when you say someone meddled
well what exactly does that mean and
here Robert Muller lays it out
specifically he says sometimes it was
pushing out messages on social media
sometimes it was paying Americans to
engage in political activities and other
times it was setting up two rallies in
the same city on the same day on
opposite sides of an issue this is the
heart of what he was tasked to do when
you look at it and it was surprised
everybody
do you see tip of the iceberg or do you
see iceberg in terms of what more he's
got to do I think it's the tip of the
iceberg what he's doing is he's laying
the groundwork here he's explaining to
the American people what happened and
now they'll continue to investigate
whether or not any Americans knowingly
participated in this because the Deputy
Attorney General he was adamant he said
there's no evidence in this indictment
that any Americans knowingly
participated in this but we know from
the indictment that the Russians did
work with Americans they paid people to
do this so the big question now for
investigators is did anyone knowingly
participate well the resident took to
Twitter and said basically he's been
cleared
that he's out of the clear is he but has
he been cleared he has not been cleared
I mean he also tweeted that this began
before his campaign which is true
there's no evidence or claim of
collusion in this specific indictment
but this is one of many and we know from
sources that sources that the
investigation continues specifically
into whether there were any financial
transactions between the Trump campaign
and Russia and then also this question
of obstruction of justice and just last
week investigators were talking again to
steve Bannon they're also speaking to
terms legal teams former spokesman so
the investigation continues nobody's in
the clear the news this week will be
that Rick Gates who worked on the
campaign was also a business partner of
Paul Manafort is likely to enter a plea
deal what does that mean in terms of him
handing over information to the special
counsel this really turns up the heat on
Paul Manafort who has so far given no
indication that he intends to cooperate
these Gates is expected to likely
provide information about men afford
they were charged together they're
co-defendants and this is all part of
the strategy because ultimately they
want men afford to cooperate to provide
information on perhaps people higher up
in the food chain perhaps the president
some of his associates whatever he has
that's really the goal so this is just
one way to really turn up the heat on
Paul metaphor and a lot of conversation
about Robert and all are keeping this
indictment top secret none of this leak
out which is extraordinary in an age
where people sell you out for a bag of
chips and a coke absolutely I mean if I
could get some of this information for a
bag of chips and a coke I would
absolutely do that
but this was a huge surprise and you
know Robert Muller is a man full of
secrets and surprises a lot of these
charges George papadopolis to the
indictment on Friday it came out of
nowhere a people didn't know and one way
he does that is that he keeps all of his
teams in little silos in little groups
so if anything leaks out you kind of
know which silo came from thank you very
much Paul